snow on the ground here and it's set to
lask for much of this week we're going
to see the cold conditions remaining but
there is change on the way there's lots
of people that aren't enjoying this cold
weather
um and want that my other conditions to
come in and it's looking like the change
will be at the weekend so in the
meantime it is very cold we've seen
temperatures as low like you said minus
17.3 degrees Celsius at braemarle last
night the coldest night of the year so
far for England as well potentially and
that's the coldest lowest temperature in
Scotland since uh February 2021 so cold
out there and we're seeing those low
temperatures
um perhaps not quite as cold in Scotland
tonight we've probably worked through
values quite as low as that but still
minus 10 possible so very cold um there
are warnings in place we do have
warnings there's snow and ice warning
across parts of Northern and Eastern
parts of Scotland into the northeast of
England as well and there is an ice
warning across the southeast of England
as well so we've got that ice from where
we've had that snow before recently
we've got the risk of eyes so we do have
that warning in place and there is also
one in case across Northern Ireland for
freezing fog and Ice as well so
wardington place and they're likely to
be further warnings issued in the coming
days as that cold being continues but
there are just three zones of weather I
think for the next few days we're seeing
the wintry showers across the northern
and Eastern Scotland down into the
northeast of England that will bring
some winter there and then we've got the
far south west where we've got some risk
of some patches snow moving in as well
but elsewhere mostly dry uh joke fully
expecting a snowman over your shoulder
when we speak to you next door get that
sorted please thanks very much indeed